Film Courage: What's your project name?
Josh Safdie: My name is Josh Safdie and I made DADDY LONG LEGS with my brother Bennie.
Film Courage: How do you feel today?
Josh: Cold,
you know it's like a day vacation
because I'm not at home.
Film Courage: What do you think separates you from all of the other filmmakers
outsides the wall of the Film Independent Spirit Awards compared to other filmmakers?
Josh: I don't think of myself as outside of
the walls of the Spirit Awards. I think it's
strange that I'm here you know I'm not
that not that I'm discrediting a film
that maybe made a very kind of
emotionally driven film a powerful movie
that people seem to respond to and I'm
very happy about that I'm very happy
that our actor is nominated for Best
Male lead where I think is
that's to me is the greatest speak
because the Cassavetes word is great you
know I mean he's a poor father American
independent cinema and I'm honored to be
in a category even named after and let
alone in the city that he loved to
interpret but it's to have our actor
nominated with movies that cost hundreds
of times over thousand times more than
aren t not that money has much to do
with it but
can you go to that time in your life
when you knew that you
over and make money
I haven't I don't know if I made my I
definitely lived my life lived off of my
films you know for like six months at a
time so that's good I still have to
figure out a way to pay the bills and do
crappy commercial work that why I still
put my all I don't think I don't mean to
demean it I put my all and everything I
do but I just wish I didn't have to
satiate my creative bone. Film Courage: In keeping with this what was your worst
survival job?
Josh: I mean I liked being a busboy at times, I was
good at it but it was
humbling. I actually know it was like
more cocky in a way I liked it I had an
enemy with the bread. Film Courage: Congratulations and thank you very much!